[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Christophe phonodi bio bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du Point et
romancier trouver refuge qui est là et
votre septième roman qui est sorti chez
Gallimard un livre qui nous emmène entre
la Grèce et la France la France ou dans
un avenir fictif mais pas si lointain on
y reviendra un homme surnommé papa un
doute Iran a pris le pouvoir et la Grèce
ou votre héros Sacha sa femme et leur
fille opposant malgré eux à ce papa vont
tenter de trouver refuge et qu'elle
refuse sur le mont Atos en Grèce là
aussi on va en reparler dans un instant
à quel besoin d'abord ce livre
répondait-il
qu'on se pose toutes et tous quand on
regarde les images qu'on vient de
regarder c'est à dire un moment si
t'ouvrit si on est plus en sécurité ou
est-ce qu'on va quel est le plan B et le
plan B pour mes personnages oui c'est ce
dernier sanctuaire au cœur de l'Europe
qu'on appelle qui existe
ce qu'on appelle le mot Atos ils sont
menacés une petite famille normale ils
sont menacés par une phrase sibyline qui
inquiète le pouvoir et il faut partir du
jour au lendemain et choisissent cet
endroit parce qu'il est inaccessible et
vous l'avez dit dans votre lancement
tout à l'heure interdit aux femmes et
aux enfants et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
disent peut-être que là-bas enfin on se
rend en sécurité alors parlez-nous de
cet endroit donc qui est un endroit très
particulier que vous connaissez qui
n'est pas Acquier un endroit qui existe
pourquoi avoir choisi cet endroit j'y
suis allé à 20 ans je voulais aller voir
ce qu'on appelle une zone grise un
endroit dont on parlait pas qui n'obéit
pas aux lois du monde qu'on connaît et
on m'avait parlé de cette péninsule qui
fait 40 km sur 10 entièrement déserte
excepté 20 monastères fortifiés qui
datent de l'an 1000 à peu près et où en
fait on est au cœur de l'Europe on est
entre la Grèce et la Turquie c'est sur
le territoire grec mais les lois du Mont
Atos ne sont pas les lois du monde qu'on
connaît en fait on vit toujours là bas
comme à Byzance comme il y a 1000 ans et
une fois qu'on entre on est dans un
autre monde un contre-monde un
anti-monde au cœur de notre monde où les
ou les lois sont celles des monastères
et même les moines qui entrent la bâche
change de nom change d'identité c'est un
peu comme la Légion étrangère donc on
arrive vraiment au cœur de l'Europe dans
un autre monde et pour moi c'était
vraiment
l'asile comme je dis l'asile à cause du
droit d'asile c'est-à-dire l'endroit où
on vous accueille et là vous êtes en
sécurité et c'est un endroit d'une
beauté hallucinante d'une nature
vraiment renversante préserver les
monastères sont fortifiés on a
l'impression qu'il sorte des pages d'un
livre de légende et j'ai été subjugué
par cet endroit et j'ai surtout tourné
peut-être 8 fois en 20 ans maintenant
alors c'est un endroit où les femmes en
théorie donc n'ont pas le droit d'entrer
c'est le seul point négatif
toutefois votre héros on va passer les
détails mais parvient à y entrer avec sa
fille et ça fait venir au premier point
important de ce texte c'est un texte sur
quelque chose qui existe assez peu en
littérature je me semble-t-il cette
relation entre ce père et sa fille je
suis content de vous l'entendre dire oui
oui je voulais écrire sur la sur la
paternité je voulais
ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui on le
voit avec l'évolution du monde c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on transmet à nos enfants
dans un monde qui devient de plus de
plus en plus chaotique comment leur
apprend à être au monde quoi être au
monde à regarder la beauté du monde à
réagir face à ce monde quand les tous
les repères
volent en éclats quand les écrans font
écran et je rêvais aussi ce roman il a
commencé par une image toute simple
c'est la main d'une petite fille dans la
grande main de son père au milieu d'une
nature considérable belle intact je ne
savais pas où c'était j'ai découvert
ensuite que c'était le mot Atos parce
que quand on écrit on a des images comme
ça et on mène l'enquête et je me suis
dit que j'avais envie d'écrire oui sur
un père et sa petite fille pendant que
la mère essaie de les sauver il y a un
personnage de femme très important mais
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un père par
rapport à ce papa dont vous parliez ce
chef de l'État qui prétend gouverner
qu'est-ce que c'est que d'être un père
un vrai père humble qui doute à qui on
n'a pas appris à être père et qui se
retrouve avec cette petite dans ce monde
aussi fascinant qu’étrange elle a un
petit peu peur cette petite fille où est
maman est-ce qu'elle va venir nous
rejoindre et puis finalement montrer que
quand on éduque une petite fille ou un
petit garçon en l'occurrence là c'est
une petite fille on est aussi transmis
bien sûr
les questions qu'elle pose finalement
nous sauve aussi la logique génial des
enfants alors cette paternité
effectivement fait écho à celle d'un
autre genre ça lui dirigeant qui a été
élu en France dans votre récit nous
sommes en 2027 il s'appelle papa donc
est là pour le coup la transmission est
à sens unique un vrai chef élu sur
l'idée d'une réappropriation de la
France par ceux qui l'aiment son parti
méditer là il aurait pu s'appeler
Renaissance tiens tiens mireac mi big
brothers sont mantra c'est il faut
parfois moins de liberté pour préserver
la liberté c'est pas un personnage tout
à fait effectif non j'ai enfin j'espère
pas être prophétique mais on le voit
quand j'ai rendu mon manuscrit au mois
de janvier il y avait pas encore la
guerre en Ukraine il y avait pas encore
des gens qui devaient trouver ref pour
le coup vraiment il y avait pas encore
la remise en question de du droit à
l'avortement aux Etats-Unis il y avait
pas encore l'Italie qui avait basculé
aussi dans le National populiste ni la
Suède donc en fait moi je me suis dit si
ça arrive en France et c'est vrai que
faire tous les sondages depuis des
années disent que les Français ont
besoin d'un chef d'un pouvoir fort
besoin d'être protégé les résultats des
dernières législatives ont montré qu'il
y avait une forte poussée des extraits
mais et effectivement j'imagine c'est un
léger décalage on est en 2027 puisque
2022 c'est maintenant on sait ce qui se
passe 2027 la France a basculé à son
tour et c'est un pouvoir alors c'est pas
c'est pas Big Brother dans la mesure
c'est beaucoup plus pervers que ça
circon dit aux gens c'est pour votre
bien on n'est pas extrême en fait c'est
on veut vous protéger il faut moins de
liberté vous l'avez rappelé pour
préserver la liberté dénoncer son voisin
c'est pas finalement dénoncer c'est
finalement agir pour le vivant ensemble
quand même
exercices qui choque c'est normal qu'on
ferme sa galerie ou que son film soit
pas montré parce que c'est pas bien de
choqué c'est aussi voilà je veux pas
aujourd'hui on nous somme de choisir
entre deux extrêmes je pense qu'il y a
une infinité de nuances moi je veux pas
être sommet de choisir mais personnage
non plus d'où cet hommage à la beauté
aussi ce qui fait que quelqu'un comme ça
arrive au pouvoir il a encore on n'est
pas tout à fait dans la fiction et vous
dites qu'on est étouffé des deux côtés
quoi qu'il y a quelque chose qui pousse
l'absence de liberté la culture de
l'offense elle est des deux côtés du
spectre politique malheureusement dans
le monde entier et et est-ce qu'il faut
choisir je pense que non je pense que
une éducation justement à la liberté à
la beauté au débat c'est justement
donner la possibilité donc aux enfants
il faut leur apprendre ça à ne pas être
sommet de choisir entre deux extrêmes
qui au fond se font la courte échelle
pour souvent à la fin l'extrême droite
[Musique]
oui de sauver le monde dans lequel on va
tous vivre
des autres le refuge proposé par votre
dictateur doux tirant et précisément la
France avec ses frontières c'est racines
chrétiennes etc chacun toutes les usions
c'est l'air de dire mais nous nous on se
on se préoccupe de tout sauf qu'en fait
vous perdez votre liberté
et même l'éducation et surveiller on
vient dire au profina et professeurs la
femme de Sacha lui est l'histoire que
vous enseignez et l'épreuve d'histoire
bah c'est pas tout à fait en fait
l'histoire qu'on voudrait voir enseigner
donc il va falloir changer et on voit en
fait que la liberté sont grignotées dans
une apparence de confort c'est peut-être
ce qui nous menace qui fait penser à la
Russie notamment sa résonne à leur
précisément avec la dernière une de
votre magazine Le Point dont vous êtes
directeur adjoint et la pluie de bombe
qui est tombé ces dernières heures sur
des civils Ukrainiens est-ce que c'est
pas un luxe de se dire qu'on peut
essayer de chercher un refuge quand on
vit par exemple quand on vit sous une
pluie de bombe exactement mais ce qui me
frappe beaucoup c'est que vous avez vu à
la rentrée scolaire en Ukraine
les écoles se sont dotées en fait de
petits refuges ils appellent ça des
Shelter c'est-à-dire en fait sous la
classe un espace justement où maintenir
cette petite flamme d'humanité c'est
aussi une des questions qui me qui me
travaille dans ce livre c'est comment on
reste humain comment on préserve cette
petite flamme d'humanité c'est pas
facile mais quand les bourrasques du
monde souffle pour l'éteindre un peu
comme dans La Guerre du Feu sauna la fin
du guerre du fond on a le feu et il faut
pas qu'il pleuve de suit il faut pas
qu'on traverse le cours d'eau et qu'on
tombe préserver ça aujourd'hui tout
contribue à nous déshumaniser la
violence qu'on voit à l'oeuvre les
pouvoirs forts un peu partout dans le
monde la technologie de tout l'hyper
technologisation de tout donc tout ça il
faut lutter contre je pense que on voit
aussi en Ukraine on voit aussi
énormément de courage énormément de gens
qui s'engagent que ce soit sur le front
ou ailleurs pour justement trouver des
refuges les refuges ils sont pas
seulement à l'extérieur trouver un
refuge et une très belle phrase de
Romain Gary comment envoyer après la
sortie du livre qui dit qu'en tant de
chaos le refuge ça peut être un paysage
ça peut être un souvenir d'enfance ça
peut être un livre et c'est aussi un
espace intérieur le refuge qui nous
permet de résister je pense que les
Ukrainiens quand ils se prennent cette
tapis de bombes là ils ont forcément un
refuge intérieur qui leur permet de
tenir sinon c'est la mort physique mais
aussi existentielle j'ai une dernière
question à avoir choisi un monde
interdit aux femmes qui dont on parlait
au début qui est celui des monastères du
monde Atos ça résonne aussi avec ce qui
se passe en Iran en Afghanistan se voit
refuser en tant que femme de ce voir
refuser la beauté la culture le
raisonnement c'était ça aussi votre
intention c'est pour ça que je voulais
perturber cet ordre patriarcal du Mont
Atos en y emmenant une petite fils vers
un germe de féminité je voulais qui est
absolument le principe féminin et aussi
pour enchanter ces moines mais
évidemment elle est clandestinement
petite fille puisqu'elle est déguisée en
garçon mais je ne vais pas dévoiler il y
a cette petite fille il y a peut-être
une autre femme sur le moins
ce matin